alors non il faut pas quitter la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme
c'est une institution qui peut nous
apporter beaucoup
elle l'a déjà fait je voudrais donnera
un seul exemple c'est sa jurisprudence
de 1976 andy sapède qui du protège la
liberté d'expression et l'arrêt à gare
on nous offre une garantie très
précieuse qui consiste à dire que toutes
les idées doivent être respectés même
celles qui heurtent choquent ou
inquiètent et ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on oublie trop souvent en france et
j'en veux pour preuve encore récemment
la dissolution de l'association
génération identitaire à mon avis on
oublie cette jurisprudence en decide
très respectueuse de la liberté
d'expression donc c'est une c'est une
cour qui peut nous donner vraiment le
bon exemple à partir du moment où nous
sommes dans la volonté de réaffirmer la
souveraineté du peuple français sur son
autorité judiciaire de ceux de s'assurer
du fait que les principes qui ont été
décidées par le peuple français et qui
sont inscrits dans d'autres droits
doivent être respectés
quoi qu'il arrive eh bien je pense qu'il
faut piquer la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme j'avais d'ailleurs
dans ce sens déposés en 2015 au
parlement je suis le premier
parlementaire d'avoir fait une notion de
révision constitutionnelle indiquant qu'
en aucun cas comment dire les les
juridictions internationales ne peuvent
prendre des décisions qui s'imposeraient
aux droits constitutionnels français ou
qui va être contre le droit français
existants
[Musique]
alors il ya deux il ya deux manières il
ya la manière anglaise puisque les
anglais l'ont quittée purement et
simplement
il ya quelques années maintenant et puis
la manière que j'avais proposée dans
cette phase qui consiste à dire que à
l'article 55 de la constitution qui
prévoit la constitution française qui
prévoit la manière dont s'articulent les
traités et notre bloc de
constitutionnalité dont l'ensemble de
nos voir ajouter une mention qui indique
que en tout état de cause la
constitution française a une valeur
supérieure à tous les traités que la
france peut avoir signé par ailleurs et
que les juges ont pour mission de faire
prévaloir ce droit constitutionnel sur
toute norme internationale y compris en
matière de brandon ce qui est une façon
de rassurer tout le monde en disant
comment dire on peut rester dans
dispositif dacourt si on veut mais le
problème c'est pas d'y rester ou de ne
pas y rester et de problème c'est de
nous libérer de la tutelle qu'elle
exerce sur votre appareil judiciaire et
sur l'autorité judiciaire et donc sur
notre souveraineté
que ce soit en la quittant comme des
anglais bon aménagement notre
constitution comme je propose une ferme
résultat sera le même
non clairement à la france n'a pas
intérêt à quitter la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme ça nous mettrait au
ban des nations européennes que dans
l'union européenne
tous nos partenaires en ont reconnu
cette juridiction
moi j'ai deux solutions pour empêcher la
cour ii continue à dériver parce que
parfois elle dérive 1 c'est vrai la
première solution c'est de changer le
mode de sélection des juges
il faut modifier flat pour recruter des
magistrats de vrais magistrats qui ont
fait leurs preuves dans de hautes
juridictions nationales
et puis la deuxième solution est bien
c'est de faire des pressions politiques
sur la cour lorsqu'on a le sentiment que
la cour s'apprête à rendre un arrêt qui
va être contraire à à nos éléments
juridiques et plus fondamentaux eh bien
il faut pas hésiter à montrer les dents
donc ya pas besoin de la quitter en
réalité les dérives
on peut les juguler
[Musique]
alors qu'il ya encore cinq ou six ans on
avait pratiquement pas le droit de
critiquer des institutions comme l'union
européenne ou la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme maintenant on peut
tout à fait librement le faire on est
beaucoup mieux entendus que par le passé
donc ça ça change la donne cela dit moi
je n'en tire pas la conclusion qu'il
faut jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain
encore une fois il faut faire un
diagnostic très objective de la
situation
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
peut nous apporter beaucoup
moi je ne crois vraiment pas sur tout ce
qui est droit à un procès équitable
liberté d'expression on a beaucoup
progressé mais mais pour le reste il
faut pas hésiter en effet à critiquer
ces institutions européennes
lorsqu'elles sont critiquables et c'est
ce que je fais et ce que monsieur
poisson fait et je crois que voilà il
faut avoir comme une position à
l'arrivée à ces mesures et il faut pas
tout supprimer pour autant j'ai publié
il ya six mois un livre qui s'appelle la
voix du peuple était un projet de
réforme institutionnelle dans lequel en
particulier j'invite à considérer que
nous devons prendre plus que des
distances à l'égard des institutions
européennes en tout cas au minimum une
distance critique et ensuite une
distance politique quant à dire
institutionnels maintenant je ne partage
pas tout à fait l'optimisme de monsieur
lebreton il compris sur des instances
françaises se trouve que j'ai eu à
quatre reprises ces derniers mois a
engagé des procédures devant conseil
d'état pour défendre les libertés
fondamentales en france qui était
attaquée et ils sont d'ailleurs de
manière très très très nouvelle dans un
silence de cathédrale si j'ose dire de
la part du conseil d'état comme du
conseil constitutionnel de la part des
libertés religieuses
je parle on va le voir d'ailleurs sur la
liberté d'enseignement avec la loi dite
sur de séparatisme on l'a vu sur le
fichage pour les opinions politiques
philosophiques et religieuses qui a été
qui n'a pas été censurée par le conseil
d'état a validé son dernier et je
pourrais multiplier ainsi les exemples
je serai premier à dire après tout si on
doit si on peu préservé dans les
distances des choses qui sont utiles
depuis les faire évoluer à la marge et
tranquillement dans le bon sens dans un
allergique normal pourquoi pas je doute
beaucoup qu'on arrive précisément parce
que c'est
q sion qui aurait dû rester en dehors du
champ politique en réalité qui sont
entrés de plain pied et c'est ça qui est
très vrai qu'à table ici la raison pour
laquelle je pense qu'il faut les en
repousser or comme helmand partiront pas
de leur plein gré la meilleure manière
c'est qu'on nous prenons nous d'autres
congés